I got to see Captain Fantastic a couple
days ago I was blown away by this movie
I really encourage you to check it out
in the film and I'm not telling you this
I'm telling you this uh-huh
you are a dad who has made the decision
to raise his kids in the wilderness in
Washington say completely off the grid
and I have to say watching the movie I
know you were very talented actor but I
could swear you really have these
survival skills you it's so convincing
no I was watching and I thought you must
look like you really knew how to start a
fire without matches yeah I could I
couldn't I could do that but I can't do
everything you see in there I mean it's
like it's make-believe right right no I
believe pretty much everything I see in
the movie that's a real bummer Vigo yeah
you better to not tell me the Lord of
the Rings stuff's fake we're kids were
much more able to do things than I was
forget the rock climbing for example we
have to do some rock climbing and I did
I really wasn't looking forward to that
and I was very happy when it was over
with but they were swinging around like
a monkey the kids are very impressive
and the rock climbing segments but it
did make me think that Vigo you if you
were trapped in the wilderness that you
would figure it out that's the
impression I got watching you in the
movie well I think anybody you know
faced with a matter of life and death or
you know no no no I'm telling you I
think you would I swear to God if I was
in a situation in the woods where I was
in real trouble I would lie down and
wait to die that's just who I am now are
you you've hunted before haven't you do
you started hunting pretty early
well actually much earlier than you
might expect that was probably four when
I shot my first duck boar well I
wouldn't say it was hunting I was
sitting on my dad's lap and he said here
you want to try and I went sure he goes
wait be patient wait or some duck I just
want bang shot in the air and a duck
follow them no you sounds like you are
the greatest hunt natural hunter in the
world
I just love the idea that you but did
you didn't pursue it much after that or
I didn't well you know that was a big
moment I mean I actually fell into the
water into the swamp where we were
sitting in front of an and night had
fallen and I and I got up off my dad's
lap and I ran into the swamp
it was winter he goes wait though and
I'm getting like duck you know and I
just why I'm half drowning right I got
this duck and I came back and it was
like a long trek home shivering I
wouldn't let go of this thing and by my
we got to the house my mom goes what the
hell is that he goes my duck no God I
mean wonder why you are wet what's going
on yeah and so I took a bath I had at
the duck I wouldn't let go but I swam it
around and you know we're not here to
talk you go at a certain point it's
gonna get real creepy I go to college I
got my god yeah I start indistinct yeah
they couldn't go I took it to bed with
me I said I'm drying it it's clean wait
I wash and and I woke up in the morning
and it was gone yeah that I goes where's
my duck and I ran and my mom is like
pulling the feathers off it over the
sink in the kitchen and I go that's my
duck she goes that's dinner and I said
alright let me pull the rest of the
feathers that okay mommy's cool
you